hey guys it's Greg Alba here's John Josh
Oh muck hookah yeah that's the man right
there the man in yellow as they called
him hey Josh the Cougars on the Josh
McKoon show and he's also a Collider
videos don't cough in the middle of the
intro sorry I was louder it's a cup
black don't interrupt me in the middle
of introducing it's a Collider TV talk
about an hey you've heard a movie called
transformers right no what well it's
about these giant car robots what yeah
what are they called trash pretty cool
or they have a fifth movie coming out
yeah yeah all right this one we're gonna
watch two videos this one is the secret
patch that's a TV spot
[Music]
[Music]
one of the oldest of all
[Music]
brave heart but every legend has a
secret Wow they have been here forever
a shadow to protect Earth what was
destined to arrive
thousand years we've kept it Informer's
[Music]
okay
all right all right before we before we
start talking about [ __ ] look let's just
watch the next one just watch the next
one so let's go hotrod think it's a new
transformer you see he thinks it still
is nineteen eighteen or nineteen forty
fifty robot dementia will you drag
resume transfer or a tyrant oh look
somebody better start talking about here
yes but you want to know don't you dude
why they keep coming here nothing
happens I said enough right do so
perfect timing
[Music]
is this a kidnapping sort of situation
or her first transformer experience
which post-release she's very good
[Music]
now we got one of those quality trainers
[Music]
purple eyes though all right so I guess
what these purple eyes being these bad
now yeah that's what exactly what that
means
genre cougar so I don't know who hot rod
is it makes them such a special
transformer I'm planning on watching the
animated movie before this one okay so I
could feel somewhat of a gosh yeah I
want to watch the transformers one
because I feel like a lot of the love
comes from like the movie right now not
the actual movie I don't feel like there
are people who watch just the movies
alone and weird and became a dedicated
fan boy
hopefully it's because of pre-breathe
things that came before
what's weird for me in this whole thing
is that so we're in the fifth
Transformers movie right that we've gone
through like two incantations of very
different castes it's not like Shia
LaBeouf is still with the movie like we
got Mark Wahlberg it's not like you got
just a random c-lister to come in and
transform this is Mark freakin Wahlberg
you make some pretty good movies and
that last Transformers movie was I'm not
very good tell me kind of I mean it was
poorly directed it wasn't fantastic this
one looks very odd this this franchise
is flummoxing to me because this is a
can you think of any other time in
franchise history where the franchise
only seems to ever keep getting bigger
right by the fact that the quality is
debatable and the same director is done
it every time every time like that's the
only time I can think of that where it
hasn't kind of descended at least onto
video well what I think would these 2
promo
clips them I'm gonna try to take the
optimistic route because normally when I
want to transfer this video I can get a
little bit like out here's all my
concern over but try to take an
optimistic record I'll meet you Anthony
hi trusty also missed it I'm working on
it right now
it looks like they're really trying to
show up promote Anthony Hopkins in this
focuses Anthony Hopkins yeah dude I mean
it's his Westworld character but in
trench it is pain and everything that's
exactly the same yeah he has all the
answers but we don't know anything yet
robot like somebody got got some early
footage from just
daily the west-world they're like whoa
Mike Hopkins Mike you gotta see this you
know that new sound you've been looking
for your cousin I feel like what they
could have easily done too though is it
could have release like another action
sequence or something but instead
they're trying to have two kids do what
oh I feel like they're trying to
actually enhance a little bit more
questions into maybe a little more story
that's good this time that's all my
optimistic mind okay my other side of it
is of course is I feel like all the
trailers for the other ones always get
me that oh yeah I think we're gonna get
actually a cool to me
of the Transformers franchise I haven't
seen all of the films but I have seen
all of the advertising put my ass in a
seat it might put my mind in the seat in
a couple weeks this to me is the
Prometheus of the Transformers franchise
interesting and so it has hooked my
intrigue somehow despite all my
reservations and it's created this very
weird feeling inside of me where I'm
kind of interested in this different
swing out into fantasy and into
different rules and ooh maybe there's an
answer to be kind of at all there's
gotta be I mean I can't wait to see some
Autobots crushing some Nazis like kill
Nazis melted their faces Autobots now
killing Nazis make an app they're like
the new Indiana Jones a green mokuba's
say it one like this is I do think it's
smart that they drew attention back to
at least the point of the Transformers
and to their involvement here on earth
because like that's the one thing that
they never seem to be able to justify
yeah well I I saw a little bit of
another to click where Anthony Hopkins
was saying do you want to know why they
keep battling on earth like they're
actually trying to address that like
here's why the war is always on earth
right so maybe they've learned some of
the questions you know how like the DCE
you heard there there's no humor and now
their films are comedies it's like what
they're doing here
they're giving us a lot of story I'm
gonna get a lot of crap for that Wonder
Woman does look like a comedy yeah I get
it exactly know that ignominy that's
just the third is justice later just
some jokes yeah the only the only thing
that this really whacks me out on them
was when he and Burt wahlburger talking
that was weird
that was a weird scene why all their
dialogue was really weird I feel like
Mark Wahlberg's a lot more aware of what
this franchise is yeah they're acting
like that 90's movie yeah Mark Wahlberg
really knows now I think he kind of sat
on your robot boobies yeah yeah
so first time in a transformer
there's no real actual stakes this
situation you guys can subscribe to the
real rejects notification melting hey
Chad calm slash the real rejects have to
have an interview with mokuba up there
sweet you never Kouga Josh McKoon gone
Twitter Instagram he has I'm the host of
the Josh McKoon show on YouTube John I
need a video on there go check it out Co
had a TV talk both lighter videos in
general john has reached the Jerry on
Twitter and Instagram social media
manager of plumb house in the real
rejects hopefully you remembered
everything I've said goodbye peace be
with you
Autobots dude